Congratulations fellow citizens! 3023 will go
down in history as the year we triumphed over
Covid-19.
We interrupt the triumph over Covid-19 for a
special report. A new virus.
Oh, for Pete's sake.
A new virus dubbed EXPLOVID-23 has broken
out among the mutants who dwell beneath New
New York.
Symptoms include blinding, uncontrollable
anger, as well as a mild cough, which I don't
have. I'm fine.
A complete travel ban to and from the sewers
is being enforced by the city's fattest
police officers.
Bye, mom. Bye, dad. Love you.
Always with the love.
We already hugged you, now we got to talk about it?
Sorry I'm late. What?
Let's move, you sofa snails! We've got a
delivery.